[Music]
First, I would like to know a little about the
audience, how many people in the public
already know the subject of quantum,
who have
and have seen something in the faculty of how many
mechanics,
because there are about 20 percent more or
less
good, the objective of this talk is to
be a  a very general idea that it
consists of computing,
especially what tools we have
in python to get into this world the
idea is that there is very little mathematics
so that it is as understandable as
possible at least for computer
science people and other
well  need for a new type of
computing
of all the people who have
worked with computers we have seen
that in recent years there has been a
growing power in the
processors that we have to our
exposure in fact there is a well-
known law of Moore's law that  in
some of its formulations it says that the
processing capacity of the
computer is going to double every two
years
and it has come  expanding
quite faithfully from the 90s
to these days
but at the cost of basically
shrinking and shrinking more and more
the transistors we have so
that for more or less 2060 it is expected that
there will be no choice but to use transistors
of  a single atom
there are some other alternatives such as
the brain chip that recently launched a
mega chip that covers a
complete 20 x 20 centimeter woofer but hey, what
is the limit that we return to
computers like the 50 lines that
have a separate room
a processor of this type consumes something like two thousand 500 watts,
which, let's say, does not make it
very practical for private use, if in
general,
then we have three points,
classical computing is based on
transistors, the limit for a
transistor is a single transistor
atom from which for this to work they
start apf it is not going to interfere with
very very important quantum phenomena
then since we have effe
quantum effects that prevent us from working well
with single atom transistors well let's
use those quantum effects for
our own good
that is let's use myself as an advantage and not
a disadvantage
well this adventure of quantum computing
has its seminal origin in
a talk by richard  feynman at a
conference the first conference on
computer physics in 1981
where
if once the photo of that
impressive conference the number of nerds who
gathered in one place where a
lot of people proposed new
alternatives for example
brownian computing that is to do computing  with the
movement of bronchial particles
another on the other hand well richard feynman
what he proposed in a fundamental talk
since that meeting that we could
use quantum phenomena to emulate
what happens at the quantum level in
nature and in this way solve
problems that computers  classical
do not have the ability to solve
because because a co  sa is to emulate
nature and another thing is to run the
simulation in nature itself
[Music]
let's say this was from the side from
our side of history
approximately in the same year on the other
side of the iron curtain also the
year 81 obviously always  a russian physicist
published a similar thesis in russian
but history made the fireman the best
known because he
writes it in english
a small timeline of the development of
quantum starts from the
theoretical proportion of benidorm
faymann in 94 it was developed in the form
theoretical the first algorithm with purposes
that could have
practical purposes in the larger
gray which was only implemented in a
quantum computer in 2001 and then there is
a succession of milestones in terms of the
number of qubits or units of
information
that can be  has managed to put together in a
single machine
and this year a couple of weeks ago there is
the supposed announcement of the
supreme quantum thus achieved by a small
problem  ma detected and implemented by
by google
in short machines to diabetics which
is still under discussion if it is good or not
before starting to try to put
a little hand
three drops of how many mechanics
here in the auditorium there is at least one
piercing in  physics so I ask you
for home plate surely you will find a
couple of things but I think it will be
understood at the level of mortals
let's say
a very common phrase attributed to faymann
some flavor to others to other people it
says that if you think you have how much
mechanics is that they are not really
understanding how many mechanics is to say
how much quantum mechanics is like the
least intuitive discipline that may
have been invented or in fact all that
goes around and even made
einstein raise his eyebrows and I don't know if even
until  the date of death was convinced
that quantum mechanics was a
representation of reality i don't think
he went to his grave denying that god
plays dice
so l  In quantum mechanics there are three
phenomena that are only the main ones and
the most different from the true
classical first the principle of
superposition
is represented by the
schrödinger cat basically there is like an
active material that has 0.5
probabilities of emitting or not a
particle the  which is detected by a
camera falls and activates a hammer that
breaks into
a poisonous potion then for the
observer who is outside that
box according to the theory of quantum mechanics
that cat is in a state alive and dead at
the same time with probability  0.5 and
there is even a
more or less potable representation at the quantum level
from the state of that system there
is also another example in the nature of its
quantum function is the verb that
are usb connectors you know that
to connect a plug to usb do
there are at least three attempts left, so
it follows that there is a state of
superposition of above and below the
states of 1  s that it is seen from
top to bottom at the same
time another very interesting phenomenon is that of
german basically the quantum state
of a particle at the moment of
measuring it is destroyed and we can only have
an approximate vision of what
happened a  for a probability that is to say
I have a charged particle
I measure it by half 10 but it is an option there is no certainty for which basically there is a probability distribution and I am going to
have to measure n times to see the
probability that this measurement is
true or false or  be it insofar as there
is no type of certainty, so
the probabilistic ones, the statisticians
are in luck because the
computation totally passes for its
range, let's say the third
tang element phenomenon, which is what one of the
things that basically repudiates einstein
is that one by  a particle 22
particles or quantum elements
separated by a certain distance can
have a function a wave function a
quantum state and equal and correl  tioned
in such a way that if I measure in one place and
in another
I will obtain the same measurement from that
way it has been achieved, for example, China
has managed to send a photon to a satellite
with another that they had on the ground, read it and
discover that they were measurements
in general  this has sometimes been to
delude people with
faster than light communication but it
is very easy to show that first for
that particle to move the limit is
always the speed of light and this does
not allow us to communicate faster
than this good guy  these are the three
rare phenomena that we have so we still
need to see what this has to do with
saving information and we are going to see
first a basic classic bit what
we are used to doing
is saving
the information in a
storage unit that can be  10 in
general with 100%
of certainty well the
storage unit of a qubit that is a
quantum system is a qubit and that in
the beat is a particular case  lar of the hobbit
in the case of the ulna you have the two
elements that are the north or south pole of
a representation that is given but
also in the equator you have a whole
area of ​​overlap where it is 0 and 1 and
in different proportions and there it is
where the schrödinger's cat moves
what is interesting in this new
representation the information good to the
superposition of data
the growth of the amount of
formation that I can store with a
qubit grows exponentially so
that with 300 cv bits I already have  2 could
be the 90 number of possibilities that
I can test compared to 300 bits
that are basically the scooby permutations it
is so far we see it as something
idealized and in reality it is an
abstract concept of the den can be presented
in many ways that meet some
condition we have qubits using the
electron spin we have some that
are ion traps this guy I understand
that there is a group in the uba that is
trying to make a
quantum computer using ion traps it would be
interesting to bring them for a talk
later there are some implemented in
super conduction circuits and others
through photons
as we represent let's say to
interact with other people who
work as a singh itself as we
represent a cobist good  have
common linear algebra presentations once a column vector in
which I have the probabilities of being
in each of the states then there is
a row vector which is the
complex conjugate and transpose of the first
and then there is another way to represent
or  I am not going to give them because we say but you
will see that it is conducive then
we have a feature called
bracket where we have the rap which is the
vector which is the vector we combine
them we multiply them and we get the bracket
that is one of the most common forms
that we have to represent it as
you see in this result
basically there is  multiply by
squaring by a factor and also
after suggesting the formula for the surface
of a sphere well the third the fourth
representation and the most graphic is called
the sphere of the blog so basically
one can represent a qubit in the state
of a cubit by a  vector in pointing
to the surface of the sphere of radius
one
the north and south poles represent the
classic 0 and 1 and all this that is here in
the equator, let's say represents the state
of pure superposition
so there we have a
graphic representation that does not scale much  If we want to
represent 50 bits, it is not better to go to the
linear algebra part, but to
understand the phenomena it is going very
well, I have three minutes left and we start
with grasses
basically how we represent the
good quantum circuits by means of
a kind of lines which
represent each  one of the
input qubits after we have we have the
basic bits which are a double line
we have a 1 gat  it is that they are like the
gates of traditional electronics that
make transformations on comics
and measuring devices as you
know once we measure out that
ulna for that one, well for that moment we
can not do anything else in general because
we destroy the quantum state and the
time that passes, that is,
read from left to right
some of the gates that exist
we have the ex gay basically flipper from
100 to 1 in the common pitch it
is a traditional electronic beat flip
and stop marc it is very
interesting because this happens  from the
pure kingdom of classical computing to
turning the cubit 90 degrees and
putting it in a state of superposition,
that is, we went from the boring element of
traditional computing to a place
of infinite dimensions to take
these circuits, that is, in  the power of
quantum computing is at the
equator in that part like it seems that
nothing is tangible
well that's where you can take
shortcuts and solve  r problems later
share it if it is not basically it takes a
control qubit if it is zero it leaves the
care of targets as zero and if it is 1
lovely but not one of the filipe a it
depends on the initial position
ok now you have already seen the word python
more or less I think that this what we saw
is the minimum we need to be able to
learn to make something compact well
imagine that now you want to start
playing implement circuits
until some doubt that is not about the
piazza and physics is there
well basically
[Music  ]
are are complex numbers 1 1 would be
points to the real part and not all of the
complex of that water field
well
we continue then that will remain while
we have to do a job on
quantum computing
ibm has a
line of solutions for several years starting from
kits kit is misspelled I am not going to
leave this on the
basis that it is like a toolkit in
python that has four earth elements
and that it is the common infrastructure
jimmy is for working on noise
which is a very important factor in
quantum air which is
for working on
specific simulators of quantum elements and
water where there are a lot of algorithms
implemented and specific and useful for
example for chemical
artificial intelligence and optimization
and also very interesting and baby it has
the quantum experience which is a
Nobel service that allows you to
design your own circuits and
run them on specific quantum computers
here I have the menu that you
gave me yesterday you have a 16-bit one in
reduce one from in ourense  in spain in
vigo well several different
destinations I have included this curator union
in an ibm save that very very fast
with 32 bits
I am going to show you more or less what it
consists of here I am already praised but
we have two types of interface this one which
is a compass  here we can compose,
let's say, the circuits the way we
want and run them on a
computer on a computer  ra quantum
or in a good computer this circuit that
I am going to show you is very simple but
I am going to be running it in different
architectures so that you can see the
differences what this circuit does is
start with a qubit that is always
at zero it passes it to the equator  let's say from
that sphere it applies a
sinnott gate and reads at the end of the
state what this does is it
generates a precise entanglement state
because because if I enter through here it
entered through the gate it stops loving and
I'm in one good the other  cube I
put it in one it is not in one time it is more
and less sorry and then always
always the reading should should be the
same as much 0001
then I run its circuits in an
emulator 1024 times
and look at the results 50.8
percent the average possibilities 0 0  and
49, that is to say, with a little medium sway,
always in a state of
endearingly, that is, 0 0 1 1, but so
that you can see the current state of
what quantum computing is
Before you come, send the same show to
a quantum computer, it is in Ourense,
notice that here it is giving me fruit,
although it is four percent of the
time the measurements were not incorrect,
that is,
it is something that in
classical computing never  we would leave a
computer 4 percent of the time
he sends me an account wrong and well here you
can see what god gave us
being in my mind in 4% of the
cases and basically what we do is we
filter the results by 120 years
then  the output will always need a
statistical criterion
while I continue I am going to test
run it on a quantum computer
but I am not going to run it more times 4,096
times supposedly due to the rules of
statistics
the error should lower the subject that almost
certainly will never be  Going down to zero
gave me 0 in the emulator, which is obviously
governed by the laws without noise from those
of the theory of the theory of
light,
well while that query runs that
computation  We move on to the next
participant who, in my opinion, is the
second most important that this ticket
is, they are solution providers and they
are manufacturing quantum computers
at this time, they offer a
range of 2 to 13 q qubits in the cloud, they have their own
programming language and  a
pact environment called will and pay queer
maybe I'm
basically successful to start with they
offer you an environment with a shot
next to it where they have loaded all the
libraries they have or I wouldn't say
no the main thing the first thing would be to
try on this side to  not to get
complicated
even if you want to run on a
real computer you have to install a
public key a whole so well
here everything is solved
well I'm going to ask a question here to
run the same
example but on a computer above it
doesn't tell me
there is a  problem probably with the
type of computer to choose I thought
with 4
or go but no then I'm going to run it
on the e  mulator
basically what we did is build they
share the same circuit we import
the gates we import the gates x if not
all we need
[Music]
we build the circuit sequentially
we ask it to provide us with a
virtual machine from 4 qubits and we run it
so now you are going to see  that I am going to
run it several times and
well this is another example
now I am going with him with him
in such a huge space
here he is telling me that I do not have
permits he is right because I asked for
11:30 so I
thought he was giving the talk at 11:00
average comes out a dollar 33 a minute this
comes out 4 dollars a minute
so here I am going to run this exercise
and notice that in an agronomic
way but always
and stable
the two results they give me
are the same 1100 that is because I think
that an entanglement
let's say virtual within the quantum computer
well it hasn't finished yet
this
well there is a third let's say resources that
I find very interesting is how much
a program e  n study is a page
in which you subscribe, you have a
lot of circuits put together by people
who are experimenting and
can also put together their own, the good thing about this
is that this meat system, once they
have it set up, they can access these
addresses and not  it is exported to all the
most popular current models of
real virtual machines of how much then
they no longer worry if I am
programming in skeet or
in william country whatever basically that is
I develop my circuit graphically
and exported it for example here it was exported
to the d format
[Music]
by pat quinn that would be given to you
let's start here
just so we can see
wood
there is a contribution in another format
that is serious as the females of the
computers of life
we ​​do this last test
and I access the address
Ok,
I'm going to copy and paste, so it seems
to me that it is a very interesting environment
to go,
let's say, gaining confidence and experience
in the two circuits.  Although there is mail
the example from the circuit
directly from the simulator well
I think that as an example let's say about
possible tools I think it's already
interesting no I'm not going to start making
more disquisitions about circuits and
others
so that we have time to ask
questions  and answers
and well, if you require any
more complex applications of the circuit, we'll talk to you
after the conference we'll
continue then we've already done that
hello world
we ran on a computer it's
still running on this program on
a real quantum computer now I
wanted to show you some applications
advanced no first I remember that I
had talked about the algorithm of the sun
well basically what it does is a
factorization of the primes and all those
who work in cryptography will sound like
breaking some cryptographic key and if
well that is the main use,
let's say the subject is  that until the moment
of the record for a circuit of sun  is to
divide 21 into three by seven children,
that is, not in any near time
using the sol algorithm we are going to
break any cryptographic key but they
are appearing
as you can see here this is a circuit
implementing sol and here the
most probable candidates appear but pay attention  in
the amount of talk that the algorithm has
at the level when a total with other
more specific algorithms was
factored four million and something in
2027 by 2017 2027
that is the record until now that is
still a bit of an episode for what
a computer is  classical but it is on the
way then there is the
well-known grover algorithm also that
from a black box function
tries to say for an output which was
the input this is an algorithm that
can never ever be lowered to the
classical level of the  n-ii theoretically the
don't see algorithm can't
square root it so when
you get to check for the
large number of data and d  moreover let's say it would be
an interesting way to demonstrate its
quantum privacy
that its quantum primacy there are many
definitions but if we reduce them something
is an algorithm that a
quantum computer runs within days
and in a traditional computer it takes
more than the age of the universe with  that
we would be crazy has not been
achieved yet but that is what he refers to
by corporal of a definition of
supremacy
and apart from that he added some papers that are
appearing that are basically theoretical
because there is no iron to run but
we already have computer vision algorithms
applying ops extraction  in
quantum computers we have a model of for
about nn of classification using
quantum computers I already believe that this
year
google has an implementation of a
pattern of using quantum circuits
well that are a little more complicated
than ours but this would be the
representation of a perceiver
in  a quantum computer
so é  l
the link that we say in it
[Music]
the view is very interesting we are in
an industry that is just in its
infancy I found it interesting even though
I am not an expert it brings up this topic
at this stage it already dates to
generate as well as a  cascade effect that
everyone begins to investigate I think they
already have the tools later if they
want more details on how to access we
can do it privately but
there are a few links there live links
well thank you very much for your attention and
I listen to the questions
[Applause]
[Applause  ]
well well thank you all very much for the
talk I don't know who has questions
how would you do to train a
neural network with a quantum sensor if
when you read it the state is destroyed
well
the important thing is
the implementation that according to him he
doesn't actually do it on computers
this type but they have a
model that comes from the same as they are
quantum computers to diabetics that
are many computers it is not known if
they are quantum computers or not but the
property they have is by quantum means they
look for minimums of energy function
let's say then the implementations
that we are seeing here if I understand it they
go that way using circuits
that to diabetics it's like they
sing only to minors
energy levels and achieve a solution but not
using these gates at the level of
gates I have not yet got into the
mechanism because the paper is from April of
this year I followed everything but with
diabetic google computers which,
by the way, they say  that they are
in the 5000 qubits that the US
Department of Defense bought from them, it becomes
much easier because you are
like giving them an objective function and minimizing
they dedicate themselves to just that, do not give them any
logic gates, nothing, they are only used
for  find that that minimum
let's say that for neural networks it comes
in handy but but they work in another
way and it is not included in this talk
because it is  It is under discussion whether they are
general computers
enough for quantum calls,
let's say I
wanted to make a query on the subject of
this flour accuracy in
calculations
4 what implications will this have, for
example in the banking system, could
this be carried out by the system that needs
that accuracy
If the future is expected
at the banking level, the models that we
are working on are also working on what is
fraud and others today are all
probabilistic, let's say what happens is that
you have an extra layer in which the
results of the computer are not
probabilistic but  however if
we know that the noise will never be
zero we can invite the results that
I saw you had 49-48 against 13 49 46
against 1 and 3 that is,
if you and you ran eight thousand times in
experiments you have an
interesting criterion to say  because this is the
value it is not that you had all close to
25% let's say something that will be a matter of
defining here for the risk of each
algorithm  tmo a threshold from
which I determine that these results
are fine,
the good thing that is going to be able is to add more
titrations until the noise drops to the
level you want,
the noise is very large, the 8,000 good,
run the 64,000 and in that the
computer  Quantum has no problem
working at the level of I think gigahertz,
that is, there is no problem running a
few more times
like this
to questions
1, of
course, because as you saw with 300
qubits, you two contemplated two per
day of the 90 possibilities, so
although not  If you did it once per
second, each run could contemplate
an exponential number of possible
possible states, that would be where
the profit is, but they can also run at
an interesting speed, that is, you
win on both sides, let's say
no to one, because the problem that did not know
any
very small problem and it is basically that a
quantum computer simulates in
quantum circuits both of them do not have
any kind of app  practical ication and it
is far away until it does not contribute
anything let's say the problem of
formalization in principle let's say
hello
what objective is mercadolibre looking for let's say
investigate in this quantum part
look sincerely
as you see I did not even make a proposal
from kindergarten let's just say maybe
give you an idea of ​​what
we have a team that lets you delirious and
seek to be in the state of the art of whatever
you want
[Music]
as you can see I didn't even do any
publicity for jaén in mercadolibre but
I think that if any of us who
are in the stick that a skinny  of
the free market I will give him enough
time to pay for the hotel and others so
that he can start researching a
cool technology that in ten
years may be the free market I
think the best initiative of Haydn that
can be given
and
[Music  ]